we don't know what's going to happen
none of the characters do it can go
south very quickly don't miss is coming
for us all
hey everybody is Charlie we got a brand
new preview from Entertainment Weekly
about Game of Thrones season 8 episode 1
as well as a couple of other details
behind the scenes about the rest of the
season so I'll just break this down like
a top 10 list there's a new round of
that fire and blood book giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave by Game of Thrones
related comment on the video what I did
was is I just broke this down to the
really important bullet points because
there's a lot of quotes from the actors
just talking about how they were crying
reading their final scripts stuff that's
not really important for the actual plot
starting with number 10 they originally
wanted to end the show with the trilogy
of movies now Dan and Dave not HBO they
said that they went to HBO HBO told them
we don't give a crap about theatrical
releases we only care about serving our
subscribers they barely make any money
from any kind of theatrical releases and
they don't earn money from advertising
the way traditional networks do HBO is a
premium cable network they get their
money from paying subscribers so they
just want to release content for them so
that they'll continue to subscribe to
HBO
Dana tape clarified that the whole
reason behind the movies idea was so
that they could do these as big
cinematic style episodes compared to
what you would see from early season
episodes like they've tried to make them
more and more cinematic spend more money
more time filming that's why it took two
years for them to make this they said
that they've been filming
start-to-finish mostly because they
spent extra time building the costumes
extra time setting the cameras up all
the things they would normally do on set
just taking twice as long to ensure
quality they didn't confirm the exact
run time of the final episodes but maybe
down the road they'll do a different
song of ice and fire story is an HBO
movie and just release it to subscribers
but I'm not gonna hold my breath on that
9 episode one they confirmed opens with
Daenerys and Jon making it back to
Winterfell it's meant to be a mirror of
the pilot with Robert Baratheon in the
procession entering Winterfell in
meeting all the Starks only this time
it's Daenerys in her procession with a
few exceptions like Jaime Lannister
coming back the second time so in cases
like his it gets really meta because you
see what he acts like when he shows up
at Winterfell during the first episode
not really caring what's going on barely
paying attention to anything shading Jon
Snow about being a bastard
let me thank you ahead of time guarding
us all from the perils beyond the wall
wildlings and White Walkers and whatnot
oh great a good strong men like you
protecting us eight jumping to the
finale though the actors when they
showed up for the final table read for
episode six remember it's only six
episodes long said that they were amazed
at how many of their characters survived
mostly talking about the core main
characters that you would consider Jon
Snow Daenerys Tyrion Cersei Jaime Sansa
Arya so it doesn't mean that they all
survived past the end of the finale it
just means that at the beginning of the
finale they're still around which is a
bit unusual given what we thought going
into this season and how they were
peeling off characters just starting to
finally kill off some of the really big
ones I almost forgot too specifically
because Gendry is always a bit of a
sticking point for people and especially
an Oreo storyline he said that he was
around for that final table read so
there is Gendry
in the final episode but that doesn't
confirm anything about where he ends up
after the finale in Maisie Williams said
that the final scene that she filmed not
necessarily the last chronological scene
but the final scene she filmed was alone
by herself so take for that what you
will use that for theory crafting seven
they confirmed all your expectations
about what those reunion scenes are
going to be like in Episode one some
characters meeting each other for the
first time like in the case of Daenerys
meeting all the stark children in the
Lords of the north some of the
characters that have more complicated
histories like Jaime Lannister having
really awkward reunions with bran stark
six they confirm that pretty much all
the non reunion scenes in that first
episode will be devoted to them making
preparations for the battle against the
night king because he's slowly sneaking
his way down to Winterfell that's one
the first really big battle is going to
take place but not necessarily the only
battle house umber up at the last hearth
is the first stop on the night Kings hit
list they didn't come right out and say
it but you don't need to be a genius to
see the foreshadowing of how that will
go down the writers want you to think
the night king is unstoppable he just
killed the supposedly unkillable wall
that stood for more than 8,000 years so
our IP numbers on their way down to
Winterfell before the big battle episode
five they confirm most of the drama of
the first episode aside from characters
happy reunions is
characters not liking Daenerys primarily
Sansa
they said that she starts out hating the
crap out of Daenerys hitting the Jon
Snow been theny and she hates the idea
that they're in a relationship together
but that all chills out after Daenerys
slowly wins her over it's the same
situation with the Lords of the north
they like Yan Royce says hate the crap
out of Targaryens so they hate Daenerys
when she shows up she slowly wins them
over for they confirmed a Redemption arc
for people like Jaime Lannister with
really complicated histories the way the
writers described it is that it's
everybody not just Jaime Lannister but
all the characters deciding what kind of
person they want to be as they stare
death in the face literally because
they're staring at the night king who's
the metaphorical representation of death
on the show but for people like Jaime
it's a bit more of a straightforward
path he's already made up his mind so
it's not like he's incredibly torn over
his decision to defend the realm they'll
bring that back around though when they
make their way back down to King's
Landing and it becomes more of a Starks
Lannister's situation because you have
Tyrion and you have Cersei that's holed
up in King's Landing you can see how
badly things might go if Cersei won't
give up the throne Tyrion doesn't
necessarily want to kill his family he
still seems like he loves them so
that'll be a much bigger sticking point
later in the series - speaking about
relationships everyone as you would
expect freaks out about Jon Snow in
Daenerys his relationship even before
anybody knows anything about his
bloodlines or him being a Targaryen
mostly that the king in the north the
person they put all their trust in has
bent the knee to her but eventually as
she wins them over they also chill out
about that relationship - so sort of
flows with Daenerys azar cos she
acclimates to all these people up in the
north because even though she's been to
the wall she's never really actually met
with the Lords of the north before but
the whole sex boat situation just is not
as big of a deal as you would have
expected when they first started
dropping those bombs I think we expected
it to be a really big deal but like they
said the main theme of the season is
about all these characters staring death
in the face and deciding what kind of
people they want to be so you can
understand they have so much to worry
about that people just ultimately won't
really care who's sleeping with who by
the end of the series but number one
biggest thing here this is actually
really exciting I'm just gonna read
their quote here it says the drama
billed to a confrontation with the army
of the Dead that's expected to be the
most sustained
action sequence ever made for television
or film they go on one episode is
supposed to be wall-to-wall action
courtesy of battle of the bastards
director Miguel Zapata neck they're
talking about Episode three that's the
first really big battle with the night
king at Winterfell the third Battle of
Winterfell so you have all Daenerys
dragons you have all their forces any of
the wildlings that survived and made
their way down every warm body in the
kingdom that's not still loyal to Cersei
throwing themselves at the night king
Peter Dinklage says it's brutal it makes
battle the bastards look like a
theme-park Dan and Dave also added the
battle doesn't just have one focus
either but rather intercuts between
multiple characters involved in their
own survival storylines during this big
battle each one feels like a slightly
different genre within this larger
Episode three battle this isn't like a
battle they're gonna spill over to
Episode four it's literally all
self-contained in Episode three prepare
up to Episode two
knocking arrives beginning episode three
they Throwdown begin episode four you
pick up in the aftermath of the battle
so it does feel like it's gonna be one
of the longer episodes of the season and
mostly that's just because you're gonna
get all these different characters
having their own storylines within the
battle so it's not like they're gonna
just flash and intercut really quickly
between people
so imagine hardhome during season five
when you have waves and waves of the
Dead crashing against the barriers in
them fighting them off imagine a
60-minute version of that fight instead
of just a portion of an episode but
here's the really big thing if you guys
have a notice there's a certain new
cycle and the way that they market shows
and movies through Entertainment Weekly
is usually they do a cover reveal they
show what the character is gonna look
like that's this Jon Snow Daenerys
poster this is the first official look
of them up at Winterfell
is that usually what happens is is this
proceeds an actual trailer dropping so I
wouldn't be surprised if in the next
couple of weeks they drop a genuine
teaser trailer so just be on general
alert whatever ends up dropping any
details anything I will totally do a
video about it but let me know what you
think about all this in the comments
congratulations Jim Gonzales you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Game of
Thrones video please email me on the
about page my channel so I can get your
contact details click here to watch the
trailer for The Witcher TV series and
click here to learn about the new
characters they just cast for the
prequel TV series thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome we'll
see you guys tonight